para irmão é a relação de Amor e Ódio
cara é igual o horário de verão tem hora
que você gosta tem hora que você acha
muito desnecessário ter não você aprende
que você não deve confiar nas pessoas
com seu irmão você vai falar Bora pedir
para mãe para nós ir jogar bola Bora
agarra embora eu eu bato e tu fala com
ela mas por que que tu só bate eu que
vou falar porque tem que ter alguém para
bater Ah pois se for amigo assim eu
mesmo bato aí e faço não mas deixa que
eu bati tu converso com ela não não é
justo isso aí vocês o cara bater meu
filho tu acha que é fácil é bater na
ponte não é fácil não é fácil Sim todo
mundo bate qualquer pessoa tão contou
que bate na porta porque vai com o
cotoquinho assim de baixo pois vai mano
bate na porta e eu falo com ela tá bom
aí a gente ia chegar lá ele batia e
corria
mamãe sair igual um demônio eu falava
mãe deixa ai ai ai
aprendi eu não confiar em todo mundo